Hello, and welcome to this intelligence squared election special with me,
Jonathan Freeland.
We are recording on November the third election day
itself for what is set to be a historic election,
really for not just the United States, but I think the entire world,
it seems to me, the entire world is biting his nails and watching this election.
And to help us talk through it and maybe even have a kind of mutual therapy
session to help some understand what's at stake.
I'm delighted to introduce our guests for this conversation.
She is the professor of American literature and public understanding of the
humanities at the university of London here in the UK.
And she is the author of behold America,
a history of America first and the American dream.
She is Sarah Churchwell. Sarah, how are you coping on this day? Week?
Well, I've been tweeting a lot and I'm glued to all of the,
um, the, you know, different facts and reactions that people are sharing. Um,
there's been a lot of joking about alcohol, uh, in the not too distant future,
um, which has only so much. Okay. So, um, yeah,
you know, I mean, I think all of us are, are, uh, reliving 2016, pretty vividly.
And, um, and I know how, how devastated I personally was by that outcome.
So, um, I actually think that, um, my nerves were worse yesterday.
I found yesterday really difficult and I mean, like personally difficult and,
um,
today it feels more like a last it's here and we're going to get this thing over
with, and of course that begs the question,
which we'll probably talk about about whether we're going to get this over with
today, but at least it's beginning.
Psychologically. I know what you mean. You almost, if it's an ordeal,
you'd rather, so let's see. Yeah, let's see. I mean,
I'm amazed and impressed that you're looking at Twitter.
I've developed all these strategies for today, which is I'm,
I'm really avoiding it. And I went for a little run this morning with, uh,
you know, the podcast in my ever deliberately.
It was about arsenal football club.
I thought I can't take anymore now of this sort of election stuff.
It's partly the sort of shouting is all over and now it is just.
Yeah, I think that's right. But I, you know, I'd say for a couple of things,
one is that I am, um, I'm at that state where I'm,
I'm so obsessed with it,
that it's a wrench to try to talk about anything else or think about anything
else. And I find not disturbing. Um, but also that, I mean,
it's just kind of overwhelming right now. Um,
so I kind of need to be overwhelmed by it. Um, but also that the way that I,
um, I have, I have been, um,
I've deliberately kind of set up Twitter as a source of information for me and
as kind of curated information from, um, experts that I trust. Um,
and so there are people who are, uh,
filtering things for me and bringing in different perspectives,
legal perspectives, um, political perspectives from, you know,
serious pollsters.
So I feel like that's helping me manage it and it's certainly an illusion of
control. Um, but it's a very important, uh, psychological crutch, right?
What if one of your curated experts tells you something that you you're just
your nerves can't bear to hear at this point?
The example I would have is a whole lot of people that were, we were w we've we,
we should come clean. I mean, you already have you that you you're,
you want to see Trump lose,
and I don't think I've met him a secret and the stuff I've written for the
guardian that I'm in the same place. So we can be honest about that,
but I had a sort of weekend freak out with this poll out of Iowa.
Now I was not even a state that people were hoping or dreaming that Democrats
could win,
but when this polls suddenly suggest to be a big shift to Donald Trump,
he was seven points ahead in a spy, you know,
in a survey done by a polling company who had previously had him more or less
level, or even behind, you know, it just sort of nerves were shredded.
So even though it was reputable people who were passing on this data, to me,
it was all my finally curated Twitter feed.
It still was enough to have me in shreds over the weekend,
which is why as a person, as a matter of personal health.
Yeah, no, absolutely.
But it's funny because it's exactly what clearly in exactly the same boat there.
But, um, but in my case, the,
the instant thing that I had to do was to go find out,
and this is cognitive bias, but I had to go find out why the salts were Paul,
which as you say, is a gold standard poll in Iowa. Um, but it was like,
this can't be right. Like this just can't be right. And so,
but also it was all kidding about cognitive bias aside.
It was actually trying to understand how that poll could account for
what was the twenty-three point shift among independents in a month from
September to the end of October, which so there's a part of that,
which we all just as, as you know, um, observers on our own, you know,
judgment have to go. We either by 23 points shift among independents,
or we don't, and we recognize that polls are predictive mechanisms,
but not absolute and all of those things.
So it was kind of like finding all of the mechanisms that would enable me to
cope with that particular poll. Absolutely.
I mean, we do, it's interesting because your, you know,
your field is American literature and of course it does range wider into
American society, but you know, you're not a psychologist nor am I,
and yet suddenly you can go right into the weeds there about kind of polling
methodologies. It's something about this contest that is sort of false.
It's made psephologists of all of us as an outlet,
really in a way for neurotic energy. Yeah.
Exactly. Right. That's what I mean,
it is a psychological crutch that we're kind of pretend, you know, claiming, or,
or, or not even claiming expertise we don't have, but, uh, um,
but trying to master the, all of this information, disinformation,
misinformation, distortion, and noise,
just trying to find some way of making sense of it in our own heads.
And yes, I come at this from, from a background in literature, are those,
you say have been,
I've been working actually on American cultural history for a long time,
but that's also means that I'm really sensitive to narrative and that this is
about trying to construct narratives, um, very consciously that, and you know,
all of my work is really about the importance of context for determining meaning
there is no meaning without context, which everybody knows on a,
on a kind of basic level,
but we often don't think about what that means in terms of the ways we talk
about politics or history or culture. And that's really my kind of research, um,
focus and interest.
And this is all just a way of creating contexts for ourselves.
We need to contextualize this information so we can make sense of it.
And yet one of those is that suddenly we all have to become highly numerous.
What is that?
Absolutely. No,
I think that's the point is that people who previously didn't have to drill into
this level of detail have, and people like you are now, you know, you know,
fully expert in, in, in the situation,
let's talk about election night as we both go into how your yourself, um,
going to plan it. I mean, what for you,
have you decided in your mind what the kind of key moment is that once you hear
that,
then you kind of know what's going on and we should say that it's an odd kind of
election day because close to a hundred million Americans have already voted as
we go into it.
It's not as if we can say this is the moment it's already been the moment for
four weeks, but do you have, in terms of when the moment the, you know,
the broadcast, first of all, which broadcast you're going to watch,
what for you is the key hour? Are you going to sleep before or afterwards?
Just talk us through your life.
Okay. Well, um, my, my plan began with taking drugs last night,
so I could sleep, um, legal over the counter drugs I hasten to add, but, uh, I,
because I wouldn't have slept otherwise and I knew I needed to, uh, um,
be able to go through today. So I don't plan to sleep tonight.
I'm just going to go straight through it. And, um, and it.
What about the disco nap before between 7:00 PM and midnight?
That's what I'm saying.
I don't think I'll be able to, I think I'll just be too hyper at that point.
Yeah. I mean, I might give it a whirl, you know, um, the, uh,
when we we'll have to see how it goes and how the energy's feeling, but, um,
I will, I always, um, since I'm in, based in the UK, like you,
I actually switched back and forth between different, um, uh,
coverage because I find all of it a little bit inadequate, um, from a distance.
But, um, the last election I was watching CNN primarily,
and I think that's probably where I'll land, but I'll be moving around.
It might be MSNBC, um, as well, but, but at least in 2016,
CNN seemed to be the fastest. Uh,
it seemed to be the most up-to-date over here in terms of cable coverage and
stuff that I could keep up with, but I don't actually,
so I'm just going to kind of bop around and see who I land on. Um,
but I'm also going to have that Twitter feed on in front of me. I'm be,
you know, watching what other people are, are, uh, saying about it. And,
um, and in terms of the States to watch, um, I personally,
we were just talking about this, uh, you know, you know, um,
super numeracy that we've all achieved,
but I actually find it really helpful to use the visual trackers on the maps
where you actually play around with the battleground States and workout pathways
to victory that way, because it really helps me visualize, um, how many,
you know, you read that, that Biden has more pathways to victory than Trump has,
but when actually start, you know, saying, well, what happens if, um, uh,
Biden takes Pennsylvania and Florida?
And then you realize that Trump literally has to take every other battleground
state and even then, yeah, I think I, I think it not started,
he can't quite get over the line. Um,
and so I think that w I think we all know what the States are to watch.
He's got a Biden, has a, unless the polls are, you know,
wildly out much more out than they were in 2016.
And as many pollsters have pointed out,
they were within the margin of error in 2016, and they had not had robust,
um, uh, polls in the, the, the kinds of, we were just talking about in Iowa.
They had not had that kind of gold standard polling in the upper Midwest States
that carried, uh, um, Trump over the line,
the 77,000 votes he got in three upper Midwest States.
Those States have now been deeply, um, um,
carefully polled and Biden is leading by somewhere between eight and 15 points
in Minnesota, Wisconsin, and Michigan, um,
and at a similar range in New Hampshire. So unless those polls are wildly off,
if we assume that Biden takes those, and he's also, um, uh,
very far ahead by early vote counts in Nevada. Um,
but unless that is completely blown out of the water,
then it does come down to the big States. It comes down to Pennsylvania,
it comes down to Florida, um, um, potentially North Carolina and Georgia,
both in play. Um, obviously the more,
the more of them that go to Biden, the better it is.
I think Pennsylvania is a must wind for Trump numerically.
You can see it mathematically. And, um, and it's clear that kind of, uh,
um, it, it, it majorly increases both candidates chances.
So Pennsylvania is the first one I'm going to be watching,
but of course they may not call it quickly if it's close,
it may take Pennsylvania several days. Um,
and the other thing that I'm very conscious of and worried bracing myself for is
the, um, is the,
the many warnings about the so-called red Mirage because of the expectation that
Trump voters are going to vote overwhelmingly in person today.
And that Biden voters were overwhelmingly voting Malin and absentee ballots.
And those are taking longer to count obviously,
and may have to be counted after the election,
which is why the Trump campaign is going after them.
And the local GOPs are going after those, those votes.
So staying I'm going to be watching what happens in Pennsylvania tonight doesn't
mean that I'll know what happens in Pennsylvania tonight, but if,
if all of the major outlets call it, um, for one, uh,
or the other, then that's going to be a pretty clear indicator.
And that should happen pretty early in the process.
I mean, it's the red Mirage thing is a very,
very good health warning for people that, uh,
that some States could look more Republican at the beginning.
And then that can sort of melt away. People are warning equally though,
down South Florida, Arizona,
Georgia could themselves have a blue Mirage where they look more Democrat
because they're, they will have taught it up the early male in votes first.
And so the early numbers might look really encouraging for Biden,
and you could then see Trump's sort of catching up as it were as the night goes
on. I mean,
it's interesting this thing about Pennsylvania and everyone is rightly sort of
focusing on that. If, as I understand it,
if Joe Biden gets one of what some people are going to the significant six,
and I think that's Florida, Texas, North Carolina, Arizona,
um, and you can throw in Iowa and Ohio,
if you get one of those it's sort of game over,
and we may not even have to get to sort of obsessing about Pennsylvania in a
way. I think the psychological test is if Florida goes to, uh, Trump,
and if Arizona goes to Trump is somehow holding one's nerve for Pennsylvania,
but people say the trouble with that is that then, because it takes so long,
Donald Trump can try and get ahead of that by saying, well,
obviously I'm going to in Pennsylvania, I, you know, one won these other States,
it's all over. I declare myself the Victor. How do you think the M you know,
American politics in the sense of Republicans in Congress and congressional
figures governors should handle and we'll handle that situation.
Well, how they should handle it as very different from how they will handle it.
Um, I think very, very clearly they've made their, um, their position on this,
uh, all too clear. Um, so you're absolutely right.
That's exactly what he'll try to do for me. The, the, um,
in many ways the worst case scenario is not even Trump having a clear win,
although that would be a terrible scenario from my point of view, but, um,
is a knife edge where the, the results look like, and there are, um,
uh, you know, again, just sticking with those battleground States. Um,
there are distributions of those States where, you know,
you end up with trumpet two 69 electoral votes and, you know, Biden at,
you know, two 71 or something. And so it's basically a dead heat.
And I think in many ways that would be the worst possible outcome, um,
because all of those divisions will just get fomented.
And because what it will do is it will start to normalize the idea that a merit,
which is,
which Trump has been trying to do to normalize the idea that American elections
are decided in the courts,
but American elections are not supposed to be decided in the courts.
That is not what should be happening. And so to get to these battleground, uh,
positions of, you know, as I say, really being balanced on a knife edge, um,
we saw what happened in 2000 with that we saw how bad that was for the country.
And in my view, that damage has continued to, um,
to divide the country. And the consequences of it are very real. I mean,
there are not enough people I think are aware of,
particularly in Europe that both Kavanaugh and Amy Coney Barrett
were, um, uh,
judicially advising the GOP in that Florida recount.
Um, in 2000, they have had a political, um,
position that is pro GOP for those 20 years. And they helped, um, uh,
convince the Supreme court that it should, um, halt the recount in Florida.
And the consequences are real.
I think I read somewhere that it wasn't just Supreme court judges, justices,
Brett Kavanaugh, and Amy Coney Barrett, but John Robinson as well.
So it was all three of them, all three of them. Yeah.
So he's now in a different place,
and this is seeming to occupy sort of now kind of centrist swing,
vote position potentially, but you're right.
They all have that amazing sort of muddle on their boots from the Florida
battle. And yet we're asking you potentially now yeah. To be, to play referee,
just to take a step back for a second. I have been in my journalism and I,
and we both have, I think in this conversation,
I've been working on the assumption that this is an absolutely pivotal election
for the United States and maybe for the wider world.
And I just want to sort of substantiate that a bit. I mean,
anybody who's covered in American elections knows that the candidates always
say, this is the most important election of my lifetime and your lifetime.
My sense is that it is this time. It's not just rhetoric, but let's,
let's hear you make the case for why this is first of all,
let's do with America and then we'll get onto the wider world.
Okay. Yeah, absolutely. Look, I think there's no question that it is.
And I would argue that there is a strong case to be made that it's the most
consequential presidential election in American history since 1796.
And what happened in 1796 of course,
is that George Washington decided not to run for third term and to step down in
order to establish the peaceful transfer of power in order to establish the
presidency was not a monarchy since 1796.
We have never had a president who didn't accept that principle until now,
um, you know, during Wars. Um, uh, so, you know,
people would say this is as consequential as rink Lincoln's reelection in 1864.
Um, yes, but Lincoln's opponent in 1864,
the Democrat McClellan accepted when he lost. And, um,
and so, you know, we can argue consequential elections,
1968 was incredibly consequential. Um, 2000,
as we've just said was incredibly consequential, not just for the United States,
but for the world does have to pause and imagine what world history would look
like if Gore had become president instead of w right.
The consequences for climate change are enormous. Um,
the consequences for the middle East and for the refugee crisis.
And many of the things that we're dealing with right now, um,
are enormous the ways in which the so-called war on terror. Well, first of all,
they wouldn't have called it a war on terror. And, and, you know,
and from there on out the ways in which, uh,
nine 11 would have been responded to in different ways.
So it's almost unfathomable how different everything would be in how
consequential that election, um, turned out to be.
So I'm not saying there haven't been other majorly important elections in us
history, but, but this one is unique in that regard.
And it is unique in that for the first time. Um,
we do not have a presumption among both the president and his
administration and among the American electorate, that the,
um, that the,
that the outcome of the election will be peacefully accepted and
that the, uh, loser will congratulate the winner.
And that goes for the losing side, uh, voters,
as well as the winning side of voters. And then we will accept the outcome and,
and move on. I found I was,
I was doing some research actually about something else. Um, but looking into,
um, newspaper coverage in 1936, and I stumbled on, um,
this kind of fascinating article about, uh,
from the American press about Roosevelt's reelection in 1936.
And it actually said, um,
everybody's so worried about FTRs election and Democrats and Republicans.
And then this editorial, um, said, but at the end of the day, we will all,
and it was just exactly that language that we will all congratulate the winner
and we will move on. And, and then he said,
and the moment that that ceases to happen,
the United States will cease to be a democracy.
And I read that a couple of days ago, and I thought, well, there is, you know,
from 1936 saying, this is the key to democracy,
and this is the first time that we've had an administration that was absolutely
refusing to adhere to that principle.
Now will all of the GOP refuse to do that, that remains to be seen?
What will the Senate do? I don't know.
I don't know what McConnell would do in such a situation,
but I don't trust them as far as I can pro him. Um,
certainly the evidence of what he's done so far is that he's,
he has absolutely no, uh, um, sense of, of, um,
of principle to the, to the, you know, to the constitution. So.
And just tell us again, who was it in 1936, who issued that warning?
That if we don't.
It was an editor, I actually tweeted it and I'll have to look it up. It was,
it was, it was a local editorial.
I want to say it was like in Wisconsin or something.
But this goes to, is the notion of loses consent. And th th th that,
that is actually a crucial,
perhaps as you've just suggested the crucial aspect of the democracy,
that consent of the loser. Uh,
and one thing it's interesting how this has been normalized.
The one thing everyone is not expecting tonight and, and, and,
and people are not holding their breath for is a concession speech from Donald
Trump. Even if it is a massive landslide on ambiguous
wind for Joe Biden,
nobody believes that Donald Trump will pick up that phone and call Joe Biden,
and then tell you supporters, I wish the new president elect luck.
That's not going to happen.
It's not conceivable. So that's, you know, that's part of the reason we start,
we started by saying that, you know, um, my nerves were worse yesterday. And,
um, part of what made my nerves yesterday was so bad was that I tried to imagine
Trump just not even conceding and certainly not graciously calling anybody,
but just admitting that it was over and that he lost. Um, and you simply can't,
you can't conceive of it. It is inconceivable that Donald Trump, um,
who we have watched closely for four years, um, would do that. So, um,
I found myself, you know, kind of taking refuge in, I mean, I, you know,
he has said at some of his rallies over the last few weeks,
he has said things like, you know, can you imagine if I lose,
I'll have to leave the country. Um,
so I find myself thinking that he's actually more likely to scuttle off, um,
you know, uh, but like the end for those who know, um,
Phillip Roth's plot against America when Lindbergh just kind of flies away. Um,
but I, I find that more conceivable that he would literally just get on a plane
overnight, if it's clear that he's lost. And if the Republicans call him up,
you know, behind the scenes and say, you know, game's up, it's over,
you've lost. Um, then him actually standing up and making the speech.
I think he just run away.
I mean, this breaks mine to my vowels,
which is not to allow myself to imagine this scenario because it's sort of,
I don't want to jinx it and it's getting too far ahead now,
but it is a fascinating thing.
There is a three month transition period in the U S system.
And it's very hard to imagine, you know, the,
the text I always think of here is the letter that George Herbert
Walker Bush left on the desk of the incoming president,
his successor bill Clinton, which is it's a, it's a genuinely moving note.
It's a very short note, but he says, essentially, you're my president now.
And I'm going to be rooting for you to do well. Your success is our success.
The idea of Donald Trump writing that note. I can't even conceive of it,
but this morning, um, Don, uh, of all people, Nigel Farage, uh,
put out a little film of himself, walking the streets of Washington, DC,
noticing how many shops and stores and banks were boarded up. Um,
and he said, this is because they're bracing themselves for violence.
If Donald Trump were to lose.
And if he were to not give the con consistent speech concession speech
we've, which we both said, we don't expect,
what cue does that sound and what would be direction do you think among his
supporters? And I'll just slip in there that image,
a lot of us saw this week of the Biden Harris bus going through Texas
being essentially like a scene out of that early, um, uh,
Steven Spielberg, film, duel, you know, being kind of driven off the road. Um,
do, I mean,
Farage is suggesting there will be violence implicitly in that film of his,
what do you think?
Well, um, for, I wanna say two things about frosh first, uh,
before I answer that question, um,
the first is that he said that he thought it would be violence on the left.
He was saying it would be Antifa violence. So, you know,
which I think is really important there because he's there,
he's trying to say that it will only come from the left. Um, uh, and,
and the pictures have gone around, um, this morning also of the white house,
surrounded by barricades. And people have been saying, you know,
he couldn't build a wall on the Mexican border,
but he managed to build a wall around the white house. Um, the, and again,
for the first time in American history, right? I mean, this just doesn't happen.
I mean,
we didn't even build a wall against the British when you guys came and burned it
down in 1812 for heaven sake.
Exactly. Right, exactly.
But the other thing that I'll say about Faraj is that it, um,
it has been, um, unexpectedly.
One of the things that's given me hope in the last 24 hours, um,
because I don't think he would have announced his little reform party if he
thought he was going to get anywhere in the United,
if you thought Trump was going to win,
he'd be over there still sucking up relentlessly to try to get a job with Trump.
So I think that is his decision to,
to return to his political fortunes in the UK, um,
bodes well for the U S if not for the UK, um, the, the,
to the question of violence, it's a very, very,
very real possibility as you say, it's already happening. So is it, uh, it's,
it's a reality there's, I don't think there's any point in, in, uh,
talking about it as hypothetical. We're seeing it happen. The question is how,
um, how entrenched that violence will get, will it just be sporadic, uh, um,
you know, and will it just be some malicious, you know, shooting off their guns?
Um, uh, you know,
but we've gotten to the point where we've got an administration that is
justifying, um, I mean, militias are armed.
Militias are illegal in every one of the 50 States. Um,
and we have an administration that is, uh,
and we've all seen it that is encouraging them and is as broad was doing
insisting that all the balances on the left and fomented on the left,
when we can all see that it's white supremacist violence on the right.
There were pictures over the weekend of protestors in front of bars,
house I'm attorney general BARR.
And they were protesting that they didn't think that the Trump administration
was doing enough to stop the left and bar went out there and like gave them
coffee and chatted with them,
although they were like armed militia in front of his house, you know? So, um,
all of that says to me that violence is a very real possibility. If anything,
you know, the, my concern would be that the left, um, my, you know,
my rollover before it,
now that might sound flippant as if I'm saying I want armed conflict in the
streets. And obviously nobody saying wants that, but is it a,
is it a viable possibility? Of course it is. And you know,
the other thing that I, you know, I say, I say this a lot,
but I think it is we're thinking about, um,
that any country that calls itself the United States is really protesting too
much. Um, and that they're, the divisions are the reality and that the,
these rhetorical moves are there to try to pull us back together again. Um,
but we have had several civil Wars. Um, the, uh,
American revolution was a civil war. It was brother against brother.
It was family member who would loyalists against family members who were
revolutionaries 75 years later. We had, um, the civil war,
the Vietnam conflict led to bombs and riots crossed the country in
68 and in the early seventies violence, you know, and, and really serious, um,
violence in ways that I think people have forgotten. So the, the, the, um,
the reality of armed conflict, unfortunately, um,
in the United States is a historical fact.
And we've actually never gone very long without it. So again, I'm not,
I hope it's clear to everybody listening.
I'm in no way I'm making light of that. And I'm in no way saying that,
that I think, you know, we should, uh, you know, um, just pass it over lightly,
but do I think it's, it's a real possibility in the coming weeks.
I mean, we,
I want us to get to the rest of the world and we must do that in a moment,
but just before we leave this, I mean,
do you spend a lot of time thinking about the 40,
41 42%,
which polls say aren't going to vote for Donald Trump despite,
as you were there. And I would,
to everything that's happened over these last four years,
even despite the handling of the pandemic,
despite some of the sort of gross remarks that sort of personally gross things
he does and says,
w w w what do you think explain explains that resilience of that vote.
And, and I suppose in a way, if he does lose the, you know,
the kind of grief they're gonna feel a sort of lost that group of people will
feel if he, this may have sort of become so attached to lose it.
Yeah. Um, I'm afraid. I mean, that's my,
my sound make me sound callous and I'm feeling I'm not,
I'm not going to spend a lot of time worrying about their feelings.
Wow.
The point and his cruelty to the people they see as their victims and their
opponents is the point. So those people who relish that cruelty,
I'm not actually going to spare them much compassion. Um,
now that's a different thing from thinking about how we,
as a democratic polity need to try to come back together. Um,
and I think we do need to try to find common ground.
We absolutely have to rebuild first. We have to just outvote them. The thing is,
is there a minority, right? So that 42%. So at the moment,
we're in a minority Prairie and rule position,
which is just untenable for anything that calls itself a democracy, but for,
particularly for such a large one as the United States,
it's simply just disenfranchise, disenfranchises, too many people. And,
and in a, in, in a very, um, uh, dramatic way, right? So that the, that the,
um, the policies of the current GOP are wildly off track with
the voting preferences of, of the vast majority of the American electorate.
So things like gun control, abortion, um, reproduction rights, um, you know, uh,
um, the, the big, hot ticket issues healthcare, um, those are, uh,
they are, um, the Democrats positions on those issues is very,
very much in track with the vast majority of the population and the Republicans
are outliers. So, you know,
the democracy is not going to hold if you don't have a representative government
that actually represents the views of the people.
So I think we have to get to that point first,
where there is more of a matchup where we're not in the situation where it's
just an eight, you know,
the setup of the United States is an 18th century Republic that this trying to
act more like a democracy.
So we've got to figure out from within ways for it to become more democratic in
its representation, numbness, or whatever that word is that representativeness,
um, in its ability to represent a larger proportion of the American people.
And then what do we do?
We work on education and we work on dismantling propaganda because the thing
that has held for 42% together is propaganda. Um, you know, there was a, uh,
we were talking about the polls over the weekend. And, um,
and there was a really interesting, um, New York times, um,
five 38 piece about the ways in which, um, uh,
new voters are coming to the, that it's a new electorate,
basically because people who didn't vote in 2016 people who've never voted in
their lives, old voters who are literally coming out, um, for the first time.
And then they were also interviewing some Trump supporters, of course.
And there was one that just hit me where this woman said she was going to vote
for Trump again, because he never lies. And I just thought, you know, you,
you're dealing there with somebody whose willful blindness and their cognitive
bias is so intense that they think that Donald Trump never lies when
he's told 22,000 lives while he's been in office.
And there was some polar other recently you'll know who it was that that found
that he's literally the biggest liar in the world.
The literally nobody has lied more than this man.
And here's a supporter insisting that he doesn't lie.
So until we get to the point where we don't have supporters saying that black is
widened up is down and day is night, I'm afraid we simply have to outvote them.
And then as I say,
we have to get back to trying to reclaim the common ground of factuality
that you know of.
No, you go ahead. You've just completed that.
About factuality, right. Is the point that, um,
that historians of authoritarianism and hotels, I mean, it's the point that, uh,
rent makes and, um, the origins of totalitarianism and she makes it again and,
and, um, her great essay on America, um,
on the politics of lying when she responded to the Pentagon papers, um,
in the early seventies, and she basically says, you know,
you don't have democracy without shared consensual ideas about facts,
and you need, um, trustworthy people telling you what the facts are,
because that's how your political system comes together.
And that's clearly what is being deliberately damaged, um, in,
in the United States. And, you know, um, I would argue, um, in the UK as well,
but that might be another conversation for another day.
That certainly is I, your point about people saying he's on,
it's really strikes a call when I was covering the campaign in 2016. And again,
actually interviewing Trump's supporters earlier this year, they repeated the,
go back to this point about him being honest. And you either,
it's some psychological thing of saying, you know, flipping the, very,
turning his weakness into a strength,
or I think it must be that on some level,
the sentences that he's not truthful factually,
but he's honest in the sense of the underlying truth, the underlying truth,
being that all these other people are evil and we're good,
and that our country has been stolen from us.
I think that must be what they mean. The very last thing,
because we're running out of time is the, is the wider world. I mean,
obviously people all over the world have become obsessed about this election.
Is there something massive at stake for people who live in Lisbon
and Liverpool and Lima in this election,
as well as for people who live in Louisville or Lexington.
So just pull those out, please.
I like a pattern. Um, but I, you know, look,
I'm suitors will have to judge for themselves.
They're obviously I'm biased here as an American who lives abroad.
I'm going to think that this, um, has massive consequences for everyone,
but I think that it does. And again, we can just name a couple of the ways, um,
when we talked about, uh, um,
the consequences from the 2000 election climate change, I mean,
simply the issue of climate change, simply the issue of, um,
you know, the, the, well, none of them are simple issues, right? But I mean,
the, the biggest issues that we face, um, as someone living in Britain and, and,
um, with an eye on what's happening in Ireland, um,
I'm very conscious of the fact that, um,
Biden and Pelosi are very clear that they will do no trade deals that will
jeopardize the good Friday agreement. So, you know, those are two really, uh,
um, prominent examples where the difference is going to be profound,
and then we can multiply those out. But in terms of just security and stability,
in terms of regrouping about what factuality looks like in terms of, um,
having a leadership that actually, you know, will criticize Putin.
Imagine that idea again, um,
and we'll hold lines against him will reinforce the importance of,
of the strategic alliances, particularly with NATO, um,
that will not just suck up to strong men and bullies around the world. Um,
that will go back to empiricism, to evidence-based thinking.
And I haven't even mentioned the pandemic. Um,
the consequences for the pandemic are immense,
unless you actually close American borders and stop them from traveling.
Even if the rest of the country gets this under control,
the United States is going to keep spreading it.
It's going to be the super spreader of the world.
So it turns out we need science.
And it turns out that with all due respect to people of faith, um,
religion ain't enough,
we need science and we need an administration that believes in science. So, um,
and believes in, in contracts that doesn't just break contracts.
So you need to know as a,
as a country that is making deals with another major power in the world
that they, uh, are, you know, the leadership can be trusted to, um,
to stick to the deals and that's, and that's crucial for, uh,
that's crucial for the economy. That's crucial for, uh, um, you know, um,
international investment in global movement of money. You have that.
We need that for the security of currencies. You know, I mean,
all of that stuff is real and people are acting as if it just kind of, uh,
you know, regulates itself. And it doesn't,
and the de-stabilizing that we've seen in the last four years has been profound,
but it will just, it will go off the charts if Trump gets back in.
So huge amounts of stake, uh, at stake for the world,
obviously for the United States itself, I was gonna say,
I'll let you get some sleep. You're not going to be able to get any or too wide.
And so, so mine, so is everyone else. Um, thank you so much,
Sarah Churchwell for this, for this conversation.
I'm Jonathan Frieden and you've been listening to intelligence squared.